hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll
a few months ago i put up a poll on
twitter i just simply said
how would you prefer to be ruled and the
two choices were according to popular
will
and by one wise and good person
the results came in they were a little
bit surprising to me it was
almost two-thirds of the respondents
said by one
wise and good person as opposed to the
popular will
i pointed out that basically you're
voting for dictatorship over democracy
and when i pointed that out people were
outraged they said well
you worded your poll very badly you
didn't say dictatorship versus democracy
you said by a wise and good person you
made the dictatorship sound
attractive that's the point the point is
that when dictatorship comes it
will sound attractive people do not just
campaign on a pro dictatorship platform
they say
i'm the one person who is wise and good
who will fix everything
this kind of attitude is extremely
attractive there are reasons why
democracies fail i know plenty of people
who i consider very very smart
people whose judgment i would generally
trust and they
seem to think that it would be good if
one really good person
was in charge of everything depends on
who the person is of course right for
some it's bill gates or
elon musk or warren buffett or barack
obama or donald trump
or bernie sanders or oprah winfrey
people can disagree who the person is
but the idea that oh we're in such a
mess
if just one person could come in and
clean everything up
that's the temptation that leads to
democracies
failing you know democracy sounds good
when you first hear about it and you say
oh yes i get a voice in how the country
is run
that sounds great i'm in favor of
democracy but at some point
you realize wait a minute you mean all
those other chuckleheads
also get a voice in how the country is
run those people are idiots i don't want
those people
to be in charge i want someone who i
actually trust to be in charge
but that's the bargain you make in
democracy
right i mean if you actually think that
democracy is a good idea you don't
simply say well i want a voice
you say i would like the actual
interests of the people as expressed by
the people themselves
to basically be how we choose how the
government is run now
of course there are details we don't
actually have plebiscites or
ballot initiatives for every single
issue in the country in a place like the
united states
we have a republic but a republic is not
something that is
different than a democracy a republic
can be democratic
as ours is the people vote for their
representatives and then those
representatives go off
and run the country if you really buy
into the democratic ideal
you're saying that you have an
obligation to try to convince
other people through the force of reason
or persuasion by whatever means
to be on your side that's a difficult
thing that's
that's something where it can be very
very annoying when you just want to say
look i'm right
let's get it done but in my personal
view democracy is worth it
yes the populist the popular will will
not always make the right choice
yes we need to protect the rights of
minorities so that the majority cannot
simply trample over them of course
there's all sorts of footnotes here
but the idea of democracy is incredibly
valuable
incredibly important so today we have a
special election day
episode of the mindscape podcast i'm
releasing this
the day before the 2020 elections here
in the united states
uh the united states is still despite
our recent failures
uh an important country worldwide so
hopefully this will be of interest to
everybody
and our special guest is dr cornell west
probably needs no introduction cornell
west is a very well-known
philosopher one of the probably one of
the most well-known public
philosophers uh in the united states in
the world today
uh he's a professor at harvard and he's
written about
many many issues he sort of came into
the public eye most obviously with a
little book
called race matters um he's also done
things like recorded a rap
album and been a cameo appearance in the
matrix trilogy so
that's a life well lived as far as i'm
concerned but he had a little follow-up
to race matters called democracy
matters and the idea of democracy the
importance of democracy and how it works
has been a motivating interest and
concern of his throughout his career
one of the interesting things about
cornell west is that clearly politically
he's very far on the left
but he has been an absolute champion and
a sincere
one and a consistent one for talking
across the aisle
for building coalitions for using the
force of reason
to try to convince people that we should
work in certain ways and listening to
them right as
as we've said before in the podcast
listening is as important as talking
when it comes to communication both ways
so um
i think this is an important discussion
to have
why is democracy grow so great you know
is democracy so great
how can we make it better what are the
failures that we have and how can we fix
them
if nothing else i hope to inspire anyone
who's on the fence to go out and vote
you know whoever you vote for
i i'm someone who thinks that the
participation in the democratic process
is just
incredibly incredibly important i know a
lot of people
especially big fans of what is sometimes
called a science podcast
i think that politics is annoying we
should get out of the way we should not
be talking about politics we should
talk about the laws of nature and
eternal truths and all that
but politics is important sorry i i have
to disagree with you there politics
is how we choose to organize our society
it's one of the most important things
we can imagine and i think that the
reason why a lot of people find it
annoying
is as soon as you start talking about it
people get emotional people's
intellectual effort goes down
and their visceral reaction goes up and
so it can indeed
be very very tiring to have political
conversations
but that does not decrease our
obligation
to do so especially in a democracy
especially when
the ultimate decisions about how to run
the
polity is in the hands of we the people
so it's in your hands go out there and
vote if you're in the u.s
go out there and vote at other times in
other places if you're elsewhere
and let's go
cornell west welcome to the mindscape
podcast well i
want to thank you for having me though
and i appreciate the work you do and
what a force for good you are
in this complicated discourse of science
and
culture and politics and meaning and
purpose was deeply appreciated my
brother
maybe i should just like let you keep on
in that vein for the next hour this is
making me feel really good
i don't know why ruin it
but no thank you very much and also i
want to before i forget send out thanks
to susie jamil
of the think ink organization in
australia she's organized
speaking events for both of us and she
was the the connection that brought us
together so
thanks to her everyone who's in that uh
down under part of the world should
check out their events
absolutely she's wonderful and when
we're
we're recording this a couple weeks
early but this podcast is going to be
published the day before election day
here in the united states
uh they just had their election day down
under in new zealand went uh it was
kind of fun and you know one way or the
other
election day 2020 is going to be
historic
right uh it's it's fraught for people on
all the different sides so i thought it
would be fun
to talk about democracy you've written a
lot about democracy
and uh it's it's one of those topics
where we kind of take
certain attitudes towards it for granted
but events of recent years have made us
sit back and contemplate what it's all
about
in a slightly uh more careful way so let
me put it
to you this way um what's so great
about democracy why what would your
sales pitch be to someone who is
skeptical that it was the best way to
organize a society
well i would say that democracy is
fundamentally
uh founded on a certain suspicion of
dogma in opposition to
domination and so i would i would begin
by saying well if someone is interested
in the socratic legacy of athens and
fundamentally believes in relentless
questioning and self-questioning
and believes that one ought to be
fallible and humble in one's orientation
toward the world
acknowledging that no one has a monopoly
on truth
then you begin to set up mechanisms of
answerability
so that with socrates dialogue is
grounded in answerability i put forward
a claim there's a counter claim there's
evidence that counter evidence argument
and counter
argument uh and at the same time the
prophetic legacy of jerusalem which has
to do
not just with that love of wisdom
grounded
in answerability and fallibility but a
deep love of
neighbor that's tied to justice and
justice here is not
just a norm that regulates various
social institutions
but it is a force in one's
education and cultivation that has to do
with trying to
unleash empathy and unleash compassion
unleash benevolence and so when you look
at those two grand pillars of the
socratic and the prophetic
and the opposition to dogma and
domination
you end up with a way of life and mode
of governance
that is grounded on filibility and
accountability grounded on a certain
kind
of concern for the other a certain
concern for neighbor in a democratic
setting it would be citizen i believe
of course in larger international and
global views so that we're
concerned with citizens of variety of
different nation states
but those are the two pillars and i
think my dear brother that
um uh you know
at the at the expense of sounding a bit
wiggish and thinking that somehow uh uh
the the
evolution leads toward us i think that
those two pillars are
some of the best if not the best forces
that we as a species have been able to
dish out
to each other and to the world and to
the cosmos
i really do it's very interesting that
humility is the first thing uh
fallibility
that that you think of because as a
scientist you know i'm very
used to hearing that science is not a
democracy people don't vote there's the
truth that is out there but the practice
of science is very much uh founded on
the idea of fallibility that none of us
is is the emperor of science anyone can
overthrow things i do see
that's also a spirit that uh energizes
democracy
you are absolutely right you remember
the great john
dewey in the gifford lectures of 1929
the quest for certainty he makes a
distinction between scientific
method and scientific temper and he
understands the way in which dogma can
surreptitiously operate within the
scientific community itself so you
become too
tied to one method so the method itself
becomes a form of idolatry but the
scientific temper
cuts much deeper and that's the socratic
energy
that's where you acknowledge a
prevailing paradigm in place you know
you're thinking of thomas coons great
texas 1962
the structure of scientific revolution
certain paradigm
frameworks certain theoretical uh uh
orientations or schools of thought
themselves can become blind spots it can
become forms of idolatry
but the scientific temper is always
critical of any kind of dogmatism even
within the scientific community
and that's why the science itself at
that deep
temperamental level that deep socratic
and dewey and level is one of the best
things that we
as a species have been able to to create
and forge and
uh uh and and pass on from one
generation to the next
uh but at the same time we also
recognize
that there are dimensions of being human
that even the great uh uh
forces and achievements of science
cannot take us
i mean here i would go with percy
shelley when shelley says poets and
philosophers
are the unacknowledged legislators of
the world he says that in the
philosophical view of reform in earlier
texts it's more famously put forward
in defense of poets where he only talks
about poets but he had poet and
philosophers
in the philosophical view of reform the
first version of that
and what he's saying is is that science
itself indispensable science itself
unavoidable crucial one of the most if
not
uh uh well i would say one of
the most fundamental armors that we have
as a species
steel doesn't take us far enough we need
we need to have to
have visions that are tied to what it
means to be human beings who have fears
anxieties and insecurities on our way
to being the culinary delight of
terrestrial worms therefore issues of
death and dread and despair and
disappointment and betrayal
have to be also attended to
and even the scientific temper gives us
a certain kind of fallible orientation
but it doesn't give us the kind of
stories and narratives and symbols
and metaphors that we need in order to
try to live lives of meaning and
significance
and so the two are so intertwined i mean
it's i'm in some ways i'm just building
on your notion of poetic naturalism no
brother
very good you already you're already
there you're already there in terms of
what i'm talking about
but uh uh you can you can see how it
resonates with with dewey's
version of naturalism or just stout's
wonderful version of naturalism
is my dear brother one of the great
naturalists alive right now or george
santayana
who was one of the towering figures who
was able to wear his form of naturalism
where the unbelievable love
of of poetry and structures of meaning
and structures of
feeling i was blessed to actually
have a teacher named nelson goodman oh
of course
it's one of the great uh philosophic
geniuses he was
he was part of the second golden age at
harvard in the philosophy department
that first golden age being of course
with james
and uh and josiah royce
santa yana in muslimburg but that
second golden age is when you were there
brother
ross and nosik and kavel and putnam but
also
goodman and nelson goodman oftentimes is
overlooked
because of those other philosophic
geniuses but he was one himself
and as you recall his particular form of
naturalism was a pluralistic one
alternative descriptions ways of world
making concerned about acknowledging
what our ends and aims are when we
create the different kinds of
conceptions of the world
so that in his dissertation that was
such a
devastating indictment of rudolph
karnap's logical
construction of the world uh where the
house bio
he said no there's a pluralism that's
inherent here
that needs to be teased out and
of course nelson goodman was also
himself an artist head of an art gallery
but
deeply concerned about a scientific
temper at that deep level not just
scientific method
and i see some deep similarities between
your notion of poetic naturalism and
those figures
but what what what what would you say my
brother
oh yeah no absolutely um in in all sorts
of ways you know
one of my cherished memories of being a
grad student at harvard was
taking classes with john rolls and and
robert nozick
and uh i i never less regret that i
didn't sit in on
uh putnam or or goodman or so many other
people and it's be
i i fundamentally this is getting way
off track for democracy but that's okay
it's a conversation oh no i
think it's connected in terms of the
guidance yes i do think it is and it's
the pluralistic aspect that connects it
the fact that
you need not just uh different political
opinions but
ideas from all sorts of corners of
the intellectual stratosphere coming in
to enrich our lives as citizens and
people
if you want to hire the best people
you're faced with the challenges both of
getting the largest pool of talent
and then looking within that pool to
find exactly the right person it's like
you're building the world's biggest
haystack
and then looking for the needle inside
it indeed.com helps you
with that task indeed.com is the number
one job site in the world
because it gives you full control and
payment flexibility over your hiring
you only pay for what you need you can
pause your account at any time and there
are no
long-term contracts plus indeed provides
powerful tools that helps you search for
exactly the right person like sponsored
jobs
which are shown to be three and a half
times more likely to result in a higher
right now indeed is offering mindscape
listeners a free 75 dollar credit to
boost your job post
which means more quality candidates will
see it fast
try indeed out with a free 75 credit at
indeed.com
mindscape this is their best offer
available anywhere so go right now
to indeed.com mindscape terms and
condition supply
offer value to december 31.
absolutely i mean you know the answer
with black people is lift every voice
not lift every echo so you don't want an
extension of an echo chamber you just
don't want
a an expression of some kind of tribal
consensus
but you want people to think for
themselves critically just like they're
going to love for themselves intensely
and by lifting every voice it cannot but
lead toward the kind of
pluralism at the high epistemic level
that
nelson goodman and yourself and dewey
and sanyon and others are talking about
but it also allows for the kind of
overlap between the the poetic and the
scientific without any kind of
narrow reductionism you're not going to
reduce poetry the science of science to
poetry
you're not going to slide down a
slippery slope to any kind of
sophomoric epistemic relativism but you
are going to have a contextualism
in recognizing the ways in which our
different
expressions are different attempts to
engage in world making
have to be able to enter public space
without humiliation
and be given a hearing based on
answerability based on mechanisms of
accountability remember that wonderful
moment
in walt whitman's democratic vistas
where he says well democracy itself is
untried why
because for the most part we don't have
conditions under which people
are willing to enter public space
without humiliation
and engage in an intense robust and
uninhibited
discussion and we would say inquiry in
the scientific context
but um but those are the kinds of
intellectual
resources that we need as democracy
itself
is undergoing such massive decay
and deterioration uh um
we need the uh we we need all the
courage in the world and of course you
got dostoevsky sitting in the corner you
know those guests
said now i told you that you're
expecting too much out of this species
they really don't have the orientation
that's required to be socratic and
prophetic
you're putting too much on their backs
the grand inquisitor is going to come in
and
give them the authority and use the
mystery
and miracle to manipulate them because
they'd rather
follow a pied piper than they would
think than they would think for
themselves they'd rather defer
uncritically to authority than be
socrates of course
most people not crazy about him like
anyway you know
[Laughter]
that's what i want to get into because
you're you're bringing us right up to
what i think is this huge
challenge that people often sort of
paper over a little bit which is that
democracy is
incredibly demanding of us i just did a
podcast with teresha
theresa bajan who is a political
theorist at oxford who's written about
civility
and her favorite characters roger
williams uh in rhode island and how
the his model of discourse was not just
let people speak but there is a positive
duty to listen to them no matter how
much
you might disagree and i think that
democracy sounds good when it sounds
like
i get a voice but people will catch on
to the fact that it means all those
wrong people get a voice too and they
become a little bit more skeptical
you are absolutely right she's
absolutely right
but again you know you can see the
connection to um to jazz here
that you can't be a jazz woman or a jazz
man without
finding your voice and moving from echo
divorce we all begin with imitation and
emulation
and have to move toward becoming
creations and becoming real
originals rather than just copies of
copies
but at the same time you can't find your
voice without
listening to other voices
voices of the dead because
the voices of the dead of course is full
of so much
wisdom tremendous blood sweat and tears
and struggling voices of the dead and
variety of different civilizations and
cultures it's got to cut across
you know skin pigmentation and gender
and sexual orientation and so forth and
so on
but at the same time you have to
cultivate
a faculty of receptivity a faculty of
listening
and yet even as you listen
you got to critically filter what you
hear
because everything you hear is not
worthy of acceptance
and that's where again answerability
sits at the center you know louis
armstrong did not like charlie parker
now you know louie armstrong is the
genius of geniuses he was wrong he's
wrong as two left shoes
yeah i know same way with einstein
vis-a-vis a
quantum mechanic you know well god
played dice with the universe okay
albert
let's see let's see let's see if the
evidence says
maybe you read too much spinoza and he's
holding just holding on too much
whatever whatever whatever's leading
towards your blind spot
but we know einstein to be you know the
great the great einstein that he was he
just didn't have monopoly on truth
either
no one does and it's funny because
that's right one of the first
one of the my favorite of my early
episodes of this podcast was with wynton
marsalis
and i kept wanting to ask him about
music but he wanted to talk about
america
and uh i see like i think you finally
answered the question for me in my mind
about what the connection
is there um between jazz or
you know group performance it could be
basketball right it doesn't need to be
jazz
uh and democracy that sort of bottom up
teamwork sacrifice in the right place
except other people's roles
kinds of things and you you have a name
for it and you wrote a book democracy
matters
where you talk about the tragicomic
tradition uh that goes into democracy
which is a little bit
which is not something i read in a lot
of political theory books so why don't
you expand on that a little bit
yeah no it's true it's true well uh you
know i was blessed
like you to uh spend a lot of good time
with magnificent teachers
uh those who had mentioned before the
nozicks and
roses and putnams and goodmans and
quines and
roderick firth and martha noose bombs
and others
but at princeton i was blessed to study
with the greatest
political theorists of democracy of the
20th century his name is sheldon
s wolan and his notion of fugitive
democracy that democracy is not so much
an institutional arrangement but rather
it is an episodic
and fugitive expression of the
visions and demands of those who are
dominated
and for the most part they will be
crushed for the most part they will be
marginalized for the most part they will
be
devalued and dishonored but their legacy
will be one in which people will be able
to remember
their vision i mean it's like you know
shelley and
and calling the philosophic
philosophical view of reform
way back in the 18 teens you know he's
calling for universal sub fridge
woman's side fridge and what have you
where they wouldn't get that until
until the 20th century where he was
ahead of his time he's not alone women
and others were doing the same thing of
course
his companion mary was even further
along than he was in that regard
but you see folk who are
trying to accent certain
values and visions and virtues that tend
to get
snuffed out that tend to get uh pushed
aside
and so there's a tragic comic quality to
that because tragic comedy is
is diffusion of tragedy and tragedy of
course is the
exercise of high levels of courage and
freedom
against limits against plato called
non-gay against constraints
and when you hit those constraints you
go under the way antigone does
or or the way a hamlet would or what
have you
but the comic is a little different
because the comic is located
in the everyday lives of people it's
quotidian the tragic historically was
reserved
only to those well-to-do uh uh
upper classes not ruling class figures
you know hamlet was a prince
and the greek characters tend to come
from very famous families
and so on whereas the the comic was
always
confined to just everyday people
but when you get a fusion the tragic and
the comic
you see then you find the richest some
of the richest
exercises of courage and freedom among
those like stone called everyday people
and that's where the democratic project
is because the democratic project
is about everyday people cultivating and
educating themselves to such a point
that they can ascend
to moral and spiritual excellence and
raise their voices to
shape their destiny their collective
destiny
with mechanisms of accountability it
could be
executive and judicial and legislative
branches trying to keep each other
accountable
or it could be periodic elections it
could be
town hall meetings where you have
tremendous conversations going on
or it could be workers councils where
you democratize the workplace
the kind of thing that uh so many
council communists and council
socialists and even distributed to it's
like
chesterton a more conservative twist but
still
very much wedded to ordinary people's
voices being
heard in that way and so the tragic
comic is really
the acknowledgement of the fragility
of the fugitivity in wolland since
democracy as fugitive usually it
hardly has a chance to sustain itself
because the powers that
be the oligarchs the plutocrats and they
come in all different colors they come
in all different
cultures and they come in all different
social systems you know the communist
systems have their own oligarchs and
plutocrats with the
political parties that don't have
accountability to the workers
uh capitalism got the monopolies and the
oligopolies and wall street that has
very limited accountability vis-a-vis or
ordinary people
and their connection with even the
elected politicians
we saw it for example in 2008 when wall
street got bailed out and
received trillions of dollars and
homeowners received
hardly anything at all not one wall
street executive
went to jail after all that insider
trading market manipulation fraudulent
activity
predatory lending and so forth but it
just shows
under capitalism of social mechanism you
still
have your oligarchs and plutocrats at
the top are
unaccountable he meets at the top and
therefore any genuine
democracy has got to be concerned about
the concentration of
power in the private and the public
sphere
and therefore it's a tragic comic affair
because
you know it tends not to be able to uh
sustain itself for too long though
brother so it's
it has a certain grimness too but it's
like the blues i mean the blues
tragic man blues is the music with
democracy hits
to political regimes you see that
it's in the minor key it's dissonant you
remember duke ellingson says
that dissonance is a way of life for
blues people
distance you stand in the minor key
you're in beethoven c minor
it's a little different than regular c
as you know you can bring in some of
those black notes brother on the piano
well this is uh this is very important
because you know
a naive reading could sort of uh dismiss
the idea that blues and jazz have
anything to do with
democracy which is politics and
government but there is
more to democracy than you show up and
vote right there's an
ongoing conversation there are there are
expressions of opinion
outside of the voting booth and they
include
explicit protests and social movements
but they also include the artistic side
of things
absolutely no we would just turn people
to read
john dewey's great classic of 1916
democracy and education
where democracy is a way of life it's a
mode
of existence it carries its own kinds of
spirit its own kind of sensibilities and
sentiments
that inform the institutions
and if the democratic institutions are
no longer informed
by a democratic spirit then they get
manipulated and dominated and
colonized by oligarchs who are operating
you say they can call it democracy all
you want
but it's not it's it has little to do
with democratic practice
and the same would be true in as you as
you noted before you know in certain
cultural
arenas you know you can have symbolic
democratic action where people are
raising their voices
listening receiving other voices and
wrestling with the kind of civilized
antagonistic cooperation and creativity
that we associate
with democracies but it would be
a jazz orchestra for example yeah and
and it doesn't have any kind of
institutional
uh uh translation in the largest society
that that largest society can be in
apartheid america which it was up until
1965.
and yet jazz was still flourishing but i
would say the same thing about
the best of scientific community this is
hillary putnam's
uh powerful point when he was in his
readings of doing i was blessed to teach
with him the last class that he taught
uh at harvard here at the in in
philosophy department
on neopragmatism that for him the
scientific community at its best
had a democratic spirit but you see
democratic experience still has
certain elitist aspects to it
uh because uh any of us who lift our
voices
know that you know you and i you know
we're not going to
we're not going to sing like johnny
hartman or frank sinatra being crosstalk
and i don't want to
be premature about your vocal no no no
you're very happy
about anything but i'm speaking for
myself you know what i mean
so that there's going to be certain
hierarchies in terms of sheer
cultivated talents and certain
cultivated gifts
but as long as they're there there's
mechanisms of accountability and
answerability and people are choosing
which particular kinds of
uh pursuits they have then there's going
to be a certain kind of
well warranted elitism that has nothing
to do with color or gender or where you
were born and so forth and so on it has
to do with the choices you make and the
gifts that you cultivate
but unfortunately people think of
elitism solely tied to
you know the vicious kinds of racisms
and sexism
and chauvinisms and tribalisms
that have been so dominant in the
history of our species
you know you make the point very clearly
incorrectly about the concentration of
power which
can seem paradoxical in a democracy if
you just let everyone vote how can it be
that the same families keep getting
elected
to the presidency and so forth but so
i mean practically speaking what do we
do
about that what is both sort of the
bottom up the duty of the citizens and
also the
top-down way we organize the system to
sort of
really let the democratic ideal
manifest itself in our actual democracy
not just in the ideals
a lot of it has to do with our our forms
of education and cultivation
because you see when you're talking
about elections you have to be as
concerned about the background
conditions
of the elections you know because we
know to be a politician
already means you need big money where
is the money gonna come from yeah what
is going to be
relation of big business providing
disproportionate amount of money this is
why my dear brother bernie sanders
was so very important unprecedented
politician at the presidential
candidacy level saying i'm not going to
take one penny
from wall street corporate elites uh uh
the power elites at all everything's
coming from ordinary people well that
was
that's unprecedented because you know
for
for as long as we can remember american
politics has been
deeply shaped by big money there's no
doubt about that
and if big money is is one of the
fundamental brooks
of fire you must pass in order to be a
politician
then you already excluded a whole wave
of people not just because of their
wherewithal but also because of their
polit their politics if they have a
critique
of wall street the way let's say brother
bernie sanders did
that he's not going to get a penny from
them anyway
so that someone like him hardly had a
chance i mean
the great norman thomas who's my one of
my uh
heroes princeton grad in 1905 in union
seminary in 1911
and ran for socialist he had a social
party for almost 50 years ran against
fdr
john dewey supported him three times
john dewey is the greatest public
philosopher in the history of the
american empire
and he's behind norman thomas well
bernie sanders is part of the tradition
of norman thomason
and eugene debs and company and monitor
king jr
when he got the call for uh the nobel
prize he said don't give it to me give
it to norman thomas i said no minute
in my own book the radical king and when
i i
published king's essay the bravest man i
ever met everybody said
martin luther king knows somebody who's
braver than him he says oh shoot i'll
fall short the bravest man i ever met
was norman thomas
now how is this black man who's known to
be the bravest and one of the greatest
visionary freedom fighters of 20th
century
talking about this vanilla brother
norman thomas
fly by the calf of princeton what is
going on well
you know like bernie sanders in the
1920s 30s 40s 50s he died 68 same
same year that martin did but he was
much older than martin of course
uh that he manifests
this unbelievable attempt to keep track
of the background
conditions of u.s elections not just the
elections themselves
and the background conditions meant he
had to have critiques
with the corporate elite he had to have
critiques
of big money donors he had to have
critiques of
those occupied movement calls of one
percent
and he got in a lot of trouble
he went to jail so many times you
couldn't even count
couldn't even count but uh but we need
exemplars i mean this is important point
i'm making though brother that
uh you have to have exemplary
figures movements institutions
uh you got to have people have to be
able to see you remember that line and
count critique of pure reason
uh i think about page 177 and the uh
camp smith translation he says examples
are the go card of judgment examples
are the go part of judgment the
judgments that we make practical
judgments that we make
what aristotle would call phronesis the
practical wisdom that we exercise
are deeply shaped by the examples that
we have in our minds
and there's much to them this is kant i
mean if anybody's obsessed with rules
yeah it's going to be the vic
moment there we said well you can't
appeal to a rule to teach you how to
apply a rule
you know that i think you reach a point
where you have to intervene
with some bedrock wisdom that that
allows us to help
get rules following off the ground
that's right and the bernie sanders
example
is a very interesting one to consider
because the democratic
primary this year for those of you who
are listening to this podcast 100 years
from now you know we had a
primary election to choose the nominee
and joe biden who was sort of the
least objectionable candidate in many
ways
won and one of the challenges of
democracy
is at some point you have to say okay my
favorite didn't win i'm gonna support
the least bad person out there and
that's that's a huge
challenge to a lot of people it seems
that you know in this particular
election people
are putting aside their objections and
moving in that direction but
i mean what kind of moral burden does it
put on you to say
that we have to accept the lesser of two
evils
well i'm i'm not sure i would use the
word except though brother
because of me i'm pushing for people to
vote
for biden but i don't endorse
him i don't accept him i'm not going to
lie about him i'm not going to
argue that somehow he's some grand
progressive that expresses
my own values and sense of being in the
world
so the crucial thing is not to fall into
the kind of
circus-like propaganda that needs
people to just tell lies about political
candidates in order to convince people
to vote for them
that for me you know if you have a
calling that is socratic
and prophetic then it means exactly what
you said you tell
people honestly you respect them enough
to be candid with them and simply say
i believe brother trump is a neo-fascist
gangster who could bring down the
curtain on the democratic
experiment therefore we must have an
anti-fascist coalition
in that anti-fascist coalition there
will be
neo-liberals like brother biden and
sister harris and brother obama
and clinton's and others who are not
in any way for me friends of poor people
or even friends of working people
but they're part of our coalition
because they're not fascists
and what trump represents is calling
into question the very possibility of
any kind of democracy that's what
fascism does
whereas with biden as a neo-liberal he's
too tied to wall street he's too tired
to pentagon militarism
he's too tight a surveillance state
there's a lot of things i'm critical of
but he's part of an anti-fascist
coalition therefore a vote for him
is a attempt to keep alive some
possibility of democracy
and you can see it goes back to sheldon
williams a rich notion of fugitive
democracy
because democracy itself is just such a
fragile thing
and that's why using the lives that long
and that's why
it's history it's really not uh it's not
a pervasive one in terms of the history
of the species and we could talk about
the last 150 200 years and see some
democratic stirrings
but generally speaking most of the
civilizations
most of the political regimes no matter
where they are
no matter where they are asia africa
latin america even i know our
indigenous brothers and sisters would
say well we had democratic forums
that were at work before the europeans
got here yes
iroquois confederation was real the
confederation was very real and so forth
but they also had some deep hierarchies
that
full-fledged democratic practices would
call into question
and so we just have to acknowledge the
degree to which as a
species we're just so tied the
egoism and tribal it was the point that
e.o wilson makes
in his uh one of his uh uh career
encapsulating and
summarizing books the meaning of
existence i mean when i read that
let's see what this grand social
biologist has to say after studying ants
and other
phenomena so well and he said look it
really comes down to trying to transcend
the pervasive egotism and tribalism of
the species in light of the fears and
anxieties that we have
he's absolutely right i mean myself you
know as a christian i've got particular
stories
that mean much to him he's an
ex-christian he comes out of evangelical
family as you know
and and made his own breaks towards
certain form of secular ways of engaging
the world
but similar kinds of concerns are trying
to get beyond
the kind of egotism and tribalism that
democracies attempt to get us to do
that's what the greeks were doing
you used to have a tribal identity now
you're going to be tied
to this demon and this demon is going to
be a
an identity that transcends your tribe
that forces you to have an allegiance to
something public
that's bigger than your tribe and that's
what
that that's what uh cliantes was trying
to kleisthenes was trying to do
and uh and and you know they they they
they made a go of it they still had
slavery they still had domestic
households they said
ugly forms of of domination was still at
work but they also
had the stirrings of a very rich
democratic
regime and we don't know of a democracy
that's not
founded in some way on the former
barbarism
on various structures of domination so
most of them are imperial
democracies they're patriarchal
democracies the modern world is off
they've often been
racist democracies but democracy has the
capacity
to speak to racist forms of domination
gender-based forms of domination
unleashing
self-determination across the board
shopping for life insurance can seem
like a daunting task there are a lot of
choices you don't know what the words
mean you're not exactly sure
what it is that you want or you need
that's why policy genius is such a help
policy genius is a marketplace it's not
an insurance company
you go to the website policygenius.com
and you can see
many different offers from different
competing top insurers
to find the right price for you you can
get life insurance for as little as one
dollar a day
and you might even be eligible to skip
the in-person medical exam
and the best part is that they work for
you not the insurance company so if you
hit any speed bumps during the
application process
policy genius will take care of
everything once you apply the policy
genius team will handle all of the
paperwork and red tape
they will get all the details right and
it's that kind of service
that has earned policy genius a
five-star rating
across over 1600 reviews on trustpilot
and google
so if you need life insurance head to
policygenius.com right now to get
started
you could save 50 or more by comparing
quotes policy genius when it comes to
insurance it's nice to get it right
are you someone who thinks that there is
um
something in the democratic ideal that
is self-correcting you know we all think
of
uh the declaration of independence and
all men are created equal
and clearly they didn't even believe
that when they wrote it right
but uh you know if had they written all
white property holding men are created
equal we might have had a very different
history for this country like somehow
they aspired to something that was
better than they were which is
which is kind of miraculous but but
probably has a down-to-earth explanation
no i i i think you're right i mean i
hear uh
i mean i could be wrong but i i'm fairly
convinced
that when you fully unleash
what i'm calling the socratic energy of
the relentless questioning the great
alfred north whitehead you remember in
his book
the adventures of ideas he says that
the noble discontent released
by socrates on the one hand what he
calls hebrew prophets
another moment he calls it critical
discontent
but this unleashing of a
critical consciousness that leads toward
a serious and candid examination
of the world now in the social world
that means you're going to come to terms
with a lot of suffering and misery
[Music]
but you also will have to come to terms
with the forms of resistance in the
forms of critique you know
in the natural world that means you're
going to have to recognize that there's
mysteries beyond your
theoretical frameworks and paradigms but
that should not
dampen your spirit in trying to
understand explain and predict
what's going on here and in in
other parts of the cosmos on earth in
other parts of the cosmos
that to me is just so rich and something
magnificent about that it has a majesty
actually
i'd be out of a job if we were not uh
still full of mysteries that we just
didn't have solved yet so i'm very happy
about that but
absolutely you know the more we the more
we discuss this
uh i don't want to say it's a downer but
but it
it highlights how much is being
asked of the people who participate in a
democracy i mean you mentioned the idea
of
you don't need to support someone but
you can still be part of their coalition
right you can keep up the criticism of
them hold their feet to the fire and yet
vote for them at the same time and
that's sort of going to be hard for some
people
to keep in their minds simultaneously
and also you mentioned exemplars you
mentioned
uh norman thomas bernie sanders people
who you're gonna
look up to and be inspired by and in the
same vein
we can't be hero worshiping of these
people right we gotta be ready to
hold their feet to the fire and say like
no look man i'm on your side almost
always but here you've gone astray and
again
it's it's a little bit askew vis-a-vis
the
human nature you know we we like to make
things black and white and democracy
is a constant balance between these
different forces we have to live in
between
well here it takes us right back to jazz
again though brother which is the notion
of improvisation
uh you have to be able to be flexible
and fluid and protein
enough to be able to shift and move
and adapt yourself now there's a real
sense in which you know coming out of
darwin's
path breaking work that one of the
distinctive features of our species
is precisely its adaptability
precisely its adaptability uh and
and so in the historical context in our
social worlds
we have to be improvisational and
adaptable but improvisational is not
just opportunities you have to have
certain kinds of disciplines that are
the basis of improvisation and by
disciplines what i mean
is being able to build on what has been
bequeathed to you
that is useful that is insightful to
build on the best
that has been bequeathed to you uh
so that you know you get that dialectic
between innovation
and tradition between creativity and
antecedent prizes
you know whitehead used to say nothing
novel is
wholly novel and
burke would add of course that nothing
old is wholly obsolete
that we're all locked into our various
traditions to build on
and so when it comes to citizens saying
okay i've got to make a choice between
let's say
dealing with trump who i'm i'm over
against but not crazy about biden
and you say well there's coalitions
where there's coming together
there's forms of relating to one another
that acknowledge the difference but
still acknowledge
that together we're able to achieve a
certain end it's like the united states
uh creating a coalition with the soviet
union to uh to crush a gangster named
hitler
now you know all the anti-communist
propaganda that was in place
in the 30s yeah for good reason stalin
was a gangster he was a thug
but without stalin's army and the u.s
army and of course russians lost about
20 million in the war we lost
about 400 000 in the war so you know who
bore most of the price
in that way but without the communists
and the capitals without
russians and the united states coming
together they would never
have crushed hitler well you see that's
that's
that's what it is to be improvisational
you have to adapt it you don't have to
tell lies about stalin and say all of a
sudden he's my ally and he's got a
wonderful social system and
now he's crushing jewish brothers and
sisters he's killing the cool lots
he's killing his close friends and so
forth and so on now he's also supporting
some liberation movements around the
world which
which is worth noting but he's still a
gangster but
we need his alliance or we must create
an alliance
with him and people do this all the time
when they're really honest
with themselves you know what i mean
yeah i do and but i do wonder you know
we were talking about life 30 years ago
when i when i was a
grad student at harvard and one of the
things that happened during my tenure
there was the berlin wall came down
right i mean the cold war ended it was
going to end at any one moment you might
pick that moment
and there was this feeling that you know
history had more or less
entered a new equilibrium phase
democracy would be everywhere and then
we'd all have mcdonald's on every
in every country and uh it hasn't quite
worked out that way and now we're
worried that
you know in in the western hemisphere uh
democracy has lost some steam that
people are more susceptible to saying
well
the government doesn't listen to me like
i'd rather just have a guy in there who
is on my side do you think that there's
some energy
that has gone out of democracy and is
there anything we can do to bring it
back
well i do think we have some energy but
going back to that moment that uh
we think of francis fukuyama's highly
influential text the end of history we
just had him in our
seminar that i teach with the uh the one
and only roberto
benji biera unger at the law school
and of course you know he's moved now
he's he was leaning toward bernie
sanders and he was deeply conservative
in those days
uh but he was thinking that maybe in
fact with the
worldwide hegemony of the united states
and with the united states very much in
the driver's seat of the work
the world the capitalist order or the
international order as it were
that there would be this kind of
homogenizing taking place
but again blind spots
blind spots start coming back and they
come back to haunt you
mainly the very consensus the very
widespread agreement among the
transatlantic countries
were too often themselves predicated on
on war and empire and foreign
interventions
you know this wonderful book by my dear
sister katrina forrester
book of in the shadow of justice
post-war liberalism
and the remaking of political philosophy
it's really a reading of john rawls
and we love john ross he was our dear
teacher and brother and so forth
but when his text was published in 1971
he was predicated on consensus and
agreement and
you had to generate these norms once you
reach a certain kind
of coming together but there's no talk
about you know the the hundreds
of operations in other countries
many many interventions by the us army
in other countries why because of the
denial of empire
and there's a disassociation of foreign
policy with domestic policy so his text
was all about
the agreement in the metropole okay
okay you have an agreement in the
metropole but there's other people
in the world yeah and your policies
are crushing some of them and it's going
to come back to haunt you
in this way and of course domestically
what comes back to haunt the united
states is not just race
it's not just slavery and jim crow and
jane crow and apartheid
but it's also class the consensus was
predicated on corporate
influence the disproportionate role
of corporate power in sustaining that
that that consensus it was a corporate
liberalism
and it was also predicated on
professionals
playing a disproportionate role and you
know and i know only what 33 percent of
our fellow citizens even go to college
right so you and i can live in a world
when we talk about harvard yale and cal
tech and we got fun and wonderful people
there and rich ideas and so forth
but for 65 percent of the folk who could
read on their own and so forth no
they're locked into very different
worlds they don't even go to college
now what happens when their suffering
becomes intense they'll either
swing to the left with bernie or
they'll swing to the right how come
because they have a contempt for the
neo-liberal elites and that's what
people
don't understand about the followers of
trump you know they're not
all racists no no they're not all races
even though too many are
but they've been crushed by neoliberal
policies of wealth distribution going
from them
to the one percent they see the greed at
the top
they see the arrogance at the top they
see the heartiness at the top
they read the new york times they read
the washington post and they
see the insularity and the parochialism
and the in-crowd jokes and so forth and
so on
and they feel put down and that populism
is going to go
one direction or another it's going to
be a left populism
it's going to be a right populism and
when it's a right populism
white supremacy is going to be the
public face because that's been one of
the ways in which there's been a
consensus on the vanilla side of the
country
keep these black folk down keep these
indigenous peoples invisible
keep these brown folks marginal and so
forth and then you get the worst of the
country and the worst of the country we
see
in brother trump himself which is a
wholesale
mendacity lying uh denial
not just denial of any form of evil not
just denial of white supremacy denial of
escalating uh uh ecological catastrophe
the denial wholesale denial of empire
any kinds of uh
of foreign policy that's tied to u.s
corporate and geo
political interests as an empire and so
you end up
you know with peter pan and and main
street disneyland
with a refuel refusal to grow up
we've grown rich and grown powerful but
like peter pan we don't want to grow up
and then we want to be on disneyland on
main street disneyland we want fun
we want smiles we don't want death
we don't want domination we don't want
dogma and all the things that are
that are part and parcel of the human
condition no we don't want those we
want some lollipops and main street
disney world
now all of us want that for our kids at
a certain moment in their lives don't
get me wrong
i took my daughter there a number of
times my son too
but i taught them the difference between
fantasy
and reality you know
when you're on the internet whether at
home or at work the last thing you want
is unwanted snoopers
listening in to what you're doing what
you want is a vpn a virtual private
network and one of the easiest ways to
get one
is with pia private internet access pia
has over 30 million downloads it's a
very simple to use application you put
on your computer and bang
you suddenly have a vpn it will keep
anything you're doing
online away from your service provider
hackers or any other form of snoopers
all of your traffic goes through a
secure vpn so that your ip address is
hidden from anybody else
and your data is encrypted and it's
available for all platforms
including mobile platforms like ios and
android you can use one subscription to
protect up to 10 devices at the same
time
and mindscape listeners get a special
url privateinternetaccess.com
mindscape you get a 30-day money-back
guarantee
and by using this special link you get
complete digital privacy for less than
three dollars a month
with three extra months for free so go
to private internet access dot com
slash mindscape and give some peace of
mind to your internet browsing
so in my more idealistic moments i i had
this idea that the most efficient
cost-effective way we could make the
world a better place would just be to
let everyone become as educated as they
wanted to be you know get
better public schools everywhere
college-free for everybody
uh do you think that's a complete
fantasy or do you think that would be a
move in the right direction
no i think it's a move in the right
direction it's just that again we would
never want to view that as a panacea
because there's forms of miseducation
that go hand in hand with these formal
institutions
associated with education it would have
to be
socratic doing prophetic
with an acknowledgement that we're going
to
always defend people's right to be wrong
here meals on liberty the classic of
1859
is very very important and this is why a
certain libertarian strand has to go
hand in hand with any democracy
rights and liberties precious they're
the precondition
of any democracy and as long as you give
people rights and liberties
there's gonna be people who deeply
disagree with you
and their voice must be heard in that
public space
that's it it's a tough thing to do i
mean to go the car you said a little bit
about this but i
i whenever people bring up roles because
i loved uh
john rolls um he i i tried very hard to
talk to him about philosophy and i never
succeeded because he liked physics
so much that once he found out that i
was a physicist he would always just ask
me questions about
cosmology in the big bang but uh but
there is this
sort of utopian aspect in his way of
doing things and
and maybe today uh habermas is someone
who
maybe in a more complicated
sophisticated way brings in this idea
that just the force of reason
can bring us to some better place and
is that too utopian i mean there's so
much else
going on with power structures and
economic worries like
do we have to be a little bit more clear
acknowledging the limitations of the
force of reason
no i think we've got to exhaust all the
forces of reason we can but it can't be
what whitehead called one-eyed reason
you see it can't be that narrow kind of
uh extr
instrumental reason that the frankfurt
school was critical of it's got to be
reason
in all of its various dimensions and of
course one of the benchmarks
of a highly wise person who wants to
unleash all the forces of reason
is to always know that reason always has
its limitations too
we don't know exactly where they are but
we know it does and i'll tell you about
rosemary ross is very complicated in
this regard he was my driver a dear
friend i
spent time at his house all the time and
you you know who was on
the the picture on his wall in his in
his office was abraham lincoln
oh okay i believe one of the great
scholars of abraham lincoln
because he came out of world war ii you
might recall he was going to be an
episcopal priest and from baltimore he
goes to princeton
he loses his faith in the war and
the problematic for ross was always a
hobbesian one the war ball against
all irrationality he had seen
massive massive suffering of course he
had grown up
you know giving two of his siblings a
disease that he had and they die
so he had a deeply deeply uh dark
conception of the human condition
so when he talked about reason it it was
grounded in a a deeply tragic
sensibility and the reason why he
he loved lincoln and read so much about
lincoln you can ask james
alec mcpherson one of the great scholars
the civil war in lincoln that he and
ross could talk for hours and hours and
rose never wrote a word harley about
lincoln
but he read voraciously about
lincoln because for him lincoln was the
one figure
who did have a tragic disposition we
know that
suffered from form the depression too
but he was trying to sustain
some possibility for rational
democratic uh experimentation in social
life
in a context of massive hatred and
contempt
and division and so rawls is problematic
really is very very dark and grim
bleak and yet at the same time he's got
this non-ideal
theory that he's working on and he's
building
from con we won't go into all of that
right now you know that and i'm sure
your listeners who read raws do too but
it's important to give rawls
his due in terms of his larger context
you know what i mean
and sister forrester does that uh
katrina does that in the shadow of
justice she actually does
because uh uh uh uh
he's right about the fragility of it i
mean i
wohlin is a political theorist of
democracy
rawls is a political philosopher of
justice and those are not the same
things
roland is much more tied in the history
right social movements contestation
rawls is at a high non-ideal uh
at a high uh normative level
in talking about the uh the ideal theory
and talking about what the norms ought
to be and how you go about justifying
those norms
that's a different way of engaging
politics
you know you you mentioned the uh the
fact i only learned about a year ago
that rawls uh had planned to be an
episcopal priest before he became
a philosopher and you you've emphasized
several times already the prophetic
strain
that undergirds some of the ways we
think about democracy but of course
democracy is traditionally a fairly
secular
project um how so you have a
secular person in the conversation with
you here how do you make the sales pitch
for the prophetic aspects of democracy
uh to a secularist
i mean one i mean we can't downplay as
you know the crucial role of religious
folk of jewish folk and
uh uh catholics and uh protestants
in forging a democratic project
sure uh because see once you democratize
and move toward the lifting of every
voice
you see i'm not sure that's a secular
project
it's simply a democratizing project in
which you recognize
that there is a public space that
transcends the secular
and the religious it it's a community
with a variety of voices
so that even calling it secular i know
my dear brother jeff stout and his
wonderful book on the
uh dissertation on the uh
the ways in which authority is
democratized
uh would call it secularization but even
calling it secularization for me
might be tilting it a little different
direction yeah i think democratization
is one that acknowledges the
indispensability
of non-religious voices the protection
of non-religious voices and the
uh and and and and and and yet also the
protection of religious voices right
also the protection of you know
so that in that so to me democracy is
much more of a hybrid
product it seems than than than just a
secular one uh
and and that's what gets us in trouble
too so when you get fights between uh
you know the church versus the state you
say wait wait wait a minute the church
has been
going at people in the church been going
at each other for a long time
i mean that's partly what what the
council movement within the catholic
church was all about right
trying to to make sure we can head off
these various internal conflicts and
then luther comes along and
boom just lowers the hammer on it but
then luther's got to deal with internal
conflicts within the lutheran church
will he be as authoritarian as the popes
were oh my god
don't hold your breath you know what i
mean yeah so that in that sense there's
a certain kind of democratizing impulse
that i think secular voices played a
very
very important role i don't want to
downplay the role that they play
but in the end you know what i know that
there's some secular brothers and
sisters who
are as dogmatic as some of our uh
jehovah witnesses no sure some of my
best friends
yes when you say god you're
very very uh parochial given your
cosmopolitan sensibility on other issues
as a secular person what's going on here
well they're human like everybody else
well this is a point i make in the big
picture where i talk about poetic
naturalism that even if you're the most
atheist person in the world
when you think about the history of
human thought some of the most
profound and careful and rigorous
thinking and ideas about the human
condition have come from within
religious traditions
so i guess i'm asking you know what if
if i am an atheist uh but i'm open to
listening to wisdom
from the religious traditions what do i
have to learn about democracy
uh from those traditions well one i mean
we really go back to where we started
uh you learn a certain humility yeah
you know i mean if you you're secular to
the core
and you read dante's comedy
and you see the ways in which he is in
awe and humbled by
all of these various voices and
individuals whose
own persistence even after death
is humanized that touch him that
move him and you say to yourself oh my
god i don't have to be catholic i don't
have to be italian i don't have to be
florentine
to resonate with his sense of
sensitivity and humility
hmm dante thank you very
very much that would be true well you
know a poem by uh
by t.s eliot or uh or w h arden and of
course the tony morrison tony morrison
was catholic a lot of people don't
don't talk about her catholicism she
went to mass
regularly and she has a deeply catholic
sensibility and
you can imagine so many of our beloved
feminists and womanists
are secular to the core they don't they
don't talk too much about the
catholicism now you see they appropriate
her as the feminist
and as a womanist but uh but but she
doesn't exist without her catholicism
she'd be the first to say that and i was
blessed to work with her for 20 years
at princeton so it's those kind of
acknowledgements i would say that
that's true across the board we could
say the same thing about
you know some of the great islamic
thinkers that are great buddhist
thinkers my dear sister bell hooks the
buddhist
written works with her i have great
respect for her was just
at her center her institute there and
berea college
recently and her buddhism goes hand in
hand with who
who she is there's no there's no doubt
about that
um i mean that's part of the beauty of
it all though brother is that
everybody's who they are and
not somebody else yep yep we that's not
what democracy is not about making
everyone alike it's about
creating a world where we can all be
ourselves right absolutely
all right we're running out of time i'm
sure we could talk for hours more but i
have two more questions
uh slight deviations from the theme but
one is i was reading just before we came
on um a story about
that that lecture course you already
mentioned you're teaching
with uh roberto unger and one of the
provocative little things you say is
that one of your goals
as a philosopher teaching students is to
unsettle them
right to make them question a little bit
some of their more standard things so
let me turn it around
in the best uh critical tradition
what is it that unsettles you what is it
what is it that you're
least confident about about the things
that you care so much about
well i mean it's what hangs in my closet
and there's one of the themes of my
writings really for the last uh
30 years which is nihilism
you know the great rabbi abraham joshua
hesto used to say the largest ecumenical
movement on the globe is nihilism
and they come in different forms there's
secular forms of it there's religious
forms of by nihilism what he very much
meant was
the triumph of tarsimicus over socrates
and plato's republic
might makes right yeah or the grand
inquisitor again and brothers care of
mazar for you
you actually give up on any quest for
truth or beauty
and you begin to manipulate and dominate
each person by keeping them
in the midst in the fog so they can't
see clearly so they don't
feel deeply especially about others on
other parts of town other parts of the
world
and that they end up acting very much in
a spirit of complacency and conformity
rather than
with courage and uh and i've been
wrestling with nihilism for a long time
schopenhauer is always right next to my
bed
in terms of the uh the figure who uh
who unsettles me probably more than
more than most uh
the other thing that unsettles me would
be the
increasing lovelessness
and joylessness in the late modern world
uh you know when dostoevsky says hell
is those who suffer from the incapacity
to cultivate
love and lovelessness is predicated on
pushing aside vulnerability pushing
aside invincibility pushing aside
humility
and so in relationships and how we
connect to each other
kindness sweetness gentleness pushed
aside it's all about posing posturing
spectacle image
trying to manipulate in order to pursue
our careers our next
opportunity and when careerism and
opportunism become
dominant even in the spirit of a people
then uh you really begin to cut off
the very things that go into love and so
you end up with a whole lot of pleasure
but not too much joy
a lot of american culture is a
joyless quest for insatiable pleasure
and the pleasure is generated by a
certain kind of titillation and
stimulation
owing to the distractions you know when
elliot says
we are distracted from distractions by
distractions and so much of them
us cultures just weapons of mass
distraction
and back to your point about education
see education is about the formation of
the right kind of intention to attend to
life
and death and love and joy and the
things that really really matter
not the superficial things but when the
superficial things become
the most dominant thing then when
younger generation grows up
with bombardment 2 and
attention to the superficial
the status the appearance
the image the spectacle and they don't
have
access to the raw stuff of caring and
nurturing
that are required for genuine love and
joy
then you end up with a whole culture
that suffers more and more from the
inability to really
love in relationships to love themselves
or to then experience the fruit of love
which is joy
so it's all about pleasure and you see
that that is spiritual decay at its most
profound
level and that unsettles me deeply
because i grew up in the context but i
had so much love in my family
in the west family and in shallow
baptist church and in the singing groups
and in our athletic groups and then
we were talking about it harvard you
know with hillary and stanley and john
and the others and that and with rorty
and
wollam we we had some deep love going on
we really did raymond goyce one of my
great teachers are still going at
cambridge
university we weren't just teacher
pupils that we really had a love and
respect and care for one another and
i'm not saying that those things are
impossible at all i'm just saying that
we're living in such a decadent culture
where things are pushing against the
love and joy
and much more towards the lust and
pleasure and that
lust for domination the lust for
attention i mean that's that's
that's trump again you see that he
becomes a sign and symptom of the
spiritual decay you can see his life
the lack of the joy i saw it with in
charlottesville with the neo-fascist
brothers when we were
we were confronted with them and they
cussing at us and so forth and you look
in their eyes brother shaw
and you see depths of joylessness it's
not just the hatred
and the contempt the joylessness you say
good god is this
brother uh i hope he has some love in
his life
because i'm here fighting him because i
love somebody and i love something
bigger than me
now he'd come back and say well i love
my race i love white cloak and i hate
jews and i hate black people and i hate
gays and so forth and so on
he said yeah but that kind of loyalty is
not the kind of love i'm talking about
see that's an idolatry at that point
well so
i think maybe the answer to my final
question is implicit in the
answer you just gave but the flip side
of that i always like to end the podcast
on an optimistic note i mean
where is it that you find hope for
you know to fight against the nihilism
you know i i maybe to
to anticipate a little bit but as bad as
things have been in this is 2020 of all
times but the tremendous energy out
there on the streets and uh
just even you know look even the energy
of people arguing with each other on
twitter for that matter like at least
they
care there's a lot of passion out there
like it gives me a little bit of hope
even if the passion is sometimes
misdirected
it hasn't gone away
no i i i it's um
i'm thinking of that line and shelley's
up prometheus unbound you remember how
he ends that great
great poem when he talks about the uh
the hope in the capital h
hope create from its own
wreck the very thing it contemplates
so that there's a possibility
actualized every day
not just on the streets in terms of
political demonstrations
marvelous marvelous multiracial and
multi-gendered multi-sexual
orientational display
but it's in what you do in terms of
scientific community
you know the magnificent energy vitality
and vibrancy
in terms of trying to make sense of the
world with the argumentation and
inducing of evidence and so forth and so
on you see
that those things themselves can be
co-opted those things themselves can be
colonized by
powers that be we still have some a
whole host of spaces that are
countervailing against any attempt to
colonize your own scientific
community so that's that that energy and
vitality
in and of itself is part and parcel of a
certain quest for truth
and even a quest for beauty in terms of
the uh
the symmetries and the incongruity that
you all see in the cosmos
and in the world uh so that i i do
believe that uh
there's always some hope but for me uh
hope is a uh as much a verb as a virtue
though brother
as long as you got some motion some
activity some dynamism taking place tied
to the love of truth goodness
beauty then we've got we've got some
real possibilities now again
you know as a christian i still have a
love of
of the holy and the love of god but
that's a very complicated issue that we
had to have another conversation on in
terms of
the traditions and stories and
narratives that go into the sustaining
of uh
particular versions of christianity that
that do overlapped in a lot of ways with
your poetic naturalism or just doubts
naturalism or santiana's naturalism or
even some of the naturalism of
of lucretia is going all the way back
but it swerves and it's different
as well because uh uh
the that that that love uh
that was manifesting that palestinian
jew named jesus
that was unleashed on that cross
is a very very powerful
narrative and story
no question yeah it means for among
other things that we will never run out
of things to talk about
which is good because i hear that you
have a podcast starting up is that true
did i make that up oh yes my dad says
trisha rose
brilliant magnificent uh person human
being that she is we have a great time
thank god brother jeremy he was the
visionary behind it
so what is the name of the new podcast
if people want to search for the tight
rope
the rope tight rope on the tight rope
balance
on the tight rope
[Laughter]
so good uh dr cornell bless thank you so
much for being on the windscape podcast
thank you so very much you stay strong
my brother you too
[Music]
you